The answer is it depends. It really depends on the type of organization. There
are many different types of businesses and organizations, and therefore,
different types of incentives may work differently in each setting. Also, the
value of extrinsic motivation, which isn't listed here can change across time.
For example, younger people may be more motivated by a high paying hourly job,
whereas those who are older may prefer a job with a good benefit plan over a
higher salary. So, our intrinsic motivations are not fixed per say. Now, if you
find this information interesting, you might pursue a career in industrial and
organizational psychology. In addition to worker productivity, I/O
psychologists also study behavioral-based safety in the workplace. Now, let's
go back to Susan.